this is this is a more ambiguous example
of from a book in a school I'm curious
your thoughts are you able to see it I'm
trying to find a good high resolution
image of it but this is from a book
called not my idea particularly a page
from the book about contract binding you
to whiteness it says you get stolen land
stolen riches special favors whiteness
gets to mess endlessly with the lives of
your friends neighbors and loved ones
and all fellow humans of color for the
purpose of profit your soul sign below
land riches and favors may be revoked at
any time for any reason it depicts a uh
hoofed footed demon with fire on top of
with money on fire a Devil's Tail and a
hand reaching for a
handshake no I think that's terrible so
this is critical race prais when they
take the ideology from Derek Beller or
kimy khaw and they put it in a
children's book and this is one of the
books they want removed from schools